There's no doubt that the Internet is
creating what is called an intelligent
planet.
That is the skin of the planet earth is
becoming a network by which intelligent
creatures communicate with each other,
but that's just the first step.
Some people think that the next step in
the coming decades is not going to be
the internet.
It's going to be brain net because we're
at the point now where we can actually
connect computers to the living mine.
In fact,
I was just at Berkeley a few weeks ago
where I had a demonstration of this.
We can actually create videos of your
thoughts.
These videos are not perfectly accurate,
but I saw a demonstration a at a
laboratory at Berkeley where you can
actually see in a video screen what
people are thinking.
So with electrodes perhaps or eeg
sensors in a helmet connected to our
brain,
perhaps one day we'll be able to have
brain to brain communication and that
gives us the possibility of brain net.
In fact,
some of the leading neurologists doing
these experiments have sear released to
propose a braid net whereby you would
exchange not just information like
typing but also emotions,
feelings because these are also part of
the fabric of our thoughts and then what
comes beyond that.
Well of course,
beyond that is science fiction and
science fiction gives us all sorts of
horror stories of things like skynet.
Maybe one day the Internet will become
sentient.
Maybe one day the Internet will think
that humans are in the way and perhaps
the Internet will take over just like in
the terminator series.
Well,
I don't think so.
The Internet is simply a way in which
minds can communicate with other minds.
We see no self awareness in the
Internet.
Now some people say,
well,
what about some kind of collective
consciousness that arises by an emergent
phenomenon?
Well,
that's a lot of Gobbledygook.
That's a lot of nice words.
Maybe,
maybe not,
but it's pure speculation at the present
time,
even in the laboratory with our finest
instruments and the latest developments
in artificial intelligence,
we cannot make a computer become self
aware.
You realize that one of our most
advanced computers,
uh,
was the IBM Computer Watson,
which defeated two humans on the the
program jeopardy.
At that point,
many pundits said,
oh my God,
the end is near.
The robots are going to put us in zoos.
They're going to throw a peanut status,
make us dance behind bars when they take
over.
Just like we make bear's dance behind
bars today.
Well,
just remember that once,
then,
no matter how fast it is,
was so stupid.
You couldn't congratulate it.
You can't go up to Watson,
slap it's transitions and say,
good boy,
you just be two humans on jeopardy.
You made history.
Let's drink to it.
You see,
Watson is an adding machine,
a very sophisticated adding machine.
It has billings of times faster than the
human brain,
but that's all it is.
It's what it's called an expert system.
It deals with formalized inputs,
formalized outputs.
You talk to an expert system every time
you're on the telephone and the
telephone says,
please hit button one,
please hit number two for the next
option.
That's called an expert system.
It's basically a sophisticated adding
machine.
That sounds like it's thinking,
but it's not.
It's simply using a formalized logic.
If you hit one,
then you go there.
If he had to,
you go someplace else.
That's Watson,
of course,
on a very,
very sophisticated level.
So I personally think that we don't have
to worry that the Internet is going to
become sentient.
Okay.